if you're looking for moments of legal
history how about the day the former
conservative Prime Minister John Major
brought his lawyers to court to accuse
the sitting conservative prime minister
Boris Johnson of lying in the UK's
highest court Lord gaya QC speaking on
behalf of Sir John legally lashed out at
mr. Johnson the inescapable inference to
be drawn is that the prayer regression
is to prevent Parliament from exercising
its right to disagree with the
government in other words Lord ganya
portrays the Prime Minister as willing
to stymie MPs and lie about his motives
because of course Boris Johnson told the
Queen his suspension was to prepare for
a Queen's speech Lord gaya says one of
the PM's advisers nikki de Costa even
wrote an article about using prorogation
as a tactic this is a person who a few
weeks before writing this briefing paper
which gives the impression that the
decision was entirely logistical was
writing in The Spectator on the 29th of
June again that is in your papers about
the possibility of a prime minister
running down the clock John Major's QC
says it's unclear where the Boris
Johnson even disputes this because he
hasn't provided a witness statement but
government lawyers claim whatever the
Prime Minister's reasons the courts have
no right to intervene the applicants and
the petitioners are inviting the courts
into forbidden territory and into what
is essentially a minefield an
ill-defined eleven justices heard
submissions on behalf of Welsh and
Scottish Government's but one from
Northern Irish lawyers was criticised by
the panel for veering into the realms of
brexit Mr Lavery I'm really worried
about your submissions so many people
are listening to you perhaps some of
them have just turned on and they will
hear these points these general points
about brexit and its effect on Northern
Ireland and it will it may come to an
entirely the wrong conclusion laney that
this is what we are looking at now don't
abuse our politeness and don't abuse
lady Hales patience
it was emphasized at the close that
leaving the EU was not the issue at
stake we are solely concerned with the
lawfulness of the Prime Minister's
decision to advise Her Majesty to probe
Parliament on the dates in question so
we have heard it is not a simple
question
it isn't easy and that's why eleven of
the country's top legal minds will
grapple with this over the weekend and
when they come back early next week as
promised they may decide that the Prime
Minister lied to the Queen they may
decide he didn't or that it's not their
place to interfere
either way this will be a unique moment
of constitutional evolution on the big
question of who has what power one
outcome is that Parliament could be
recalled next week but depending on the
judgement it may still be possible for
the Prime Minister to suspend it again
Jason Farrell Sky News